ce à quoi j'ai vu qu'on avait fait un
grand professionnel parce que je les ai
vus j'ai vu dieu du coin de l'oeil
quand il a vu que je faisais le tour et
il s'est dit il va arriver à moi il va
me demander le bac donc il faut que je
sois prêt c'est co-éco équipe bis
je crois que c'est le mec le mieux
accueilli du montât vital et à une
petite audi dans le nord a légué par
dans le nord et que ça coûtait 50 ans a
réussi un bon 50 en dessous c'est un des
buts du nord et c'est un gosse beaucoup
mangé pendant l'été l'hiver est là prix
plate fricadelle je peux tu vois ce que
cette voie de ski free fait qu'abaisser
l'intrus que dans tout et ça donne gros
s'effrite mois ce groupe et il monte sur
la balance parce qu'il me faisait tant
qu il monte sur la balance comme ça puis
quand il sur la balance rempl vente
j'évoque les ventes et où il ya sa femme
qui passe et elle le voit débat aura le
pôle vente sur la valeur c'est ridicule
dit ben non c'est pas ridicule pour voir
les chiffres c'est le fils de jean-marie
qui dit qui dit papa de smart à meyrin
il dit papa comment on fait les bébés et
là il dit bon c'est très simple c'est à
dire papa il mais il met la petite
graine dans le chouchou de maman à et
après babri pouces avec sa grosse [ __ ]
c2a qui s'endorment dans le back up sont
comme ça il y en a un qui regarde
l'autre le voir et rien d'autre alors
ces deux autres sites de ce don qui ça
sert d'avoir l'image ils sont dans le
back up ça comme ça vient retournac qui
regarde l'autre comme ça il fait 1
je n'ai pas vu tes a pas l'air bien tu
as des tas des poils des thés verts
l'eau tu dis mais c'est peut-être parce
que je suis inquiet oui abruti
une vieille dame qui rentre dans
l'ascenseur est comme ça fait très laid
très très vieille très vieille et
danseurs comme le fait la gueule non
parce que l'offre était plus l'ascenseur
s'ouvrent à l'étagé une très belle
blonde qui rentre comme ça tu vas gens
posent instagram et qui se retourne vers
lavier et lui dit dior 100 euros la
bouteille et la porte se referme ça
descend d'un étage il ya une autre fille
blonde très belle encore plus belle qui
hante encore plus parfumé qui regardent
la vieille dame a griffé chanel 300
euros la bouteille et ça arrive au
rez-de-chaussée la porte s'ouvre et la
petite vieille elle sort et elle largue
une énorme caisse et elle se retourna
fait flageolets de chez lidl 400e et en
béton ans invite tous les jours c'est
minime ça même mais allez problème
conjugal eu d'écouté alors je suis très
embêté parce que je suis pas sexologue
tchèque généraliste mais moi je serais
vous je sais pas par les fantasmes ne
pas parler de cul par des experts
et la dame à la normale du bo battu et
je vais l'acheter les culottes et
l'agriculteur un peu comme didier de
l'amour est dans le pré tu vois il fait
non non non elle dit mais pourquoi mais
bien le cul d'une moissonneuse-batteuse
tuer le cul d'une moissonneuse-batteuse
devient alors la fille a fait une
première boutique à sauriens deux trois
quatre boutiques rien du tout ils
trouvent pas de culotte et ventre elle
sera revenue il se couche et el marikh
et dans le lit qui à côté c j'aimerais
j'aimerais bien une cale un petit gamin
qui me touche mais l'association ne veut
pas faire le gala parce que c'est pas
maintenant hautement moissonneuses
batteuses pour atout p'tit brin d'herbe
ses deux filles qui sont sur une
terrasse comme sabia discutent de trucs
très très perso et tout tient à une des
deux qui voit arriver son mari à ses
aléas il est venu avec un bouquet de
fleurs tout ce qui passait bien ah non
il va encore vouloir faire des trucs va
falloir que j'écarte les jambes ce soir
quand elle sait pas pourquoi t'as pas de
buzz
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]